digamos que este rectángulo verde este
rectángulo de aquí tiene un área de 268
unidades cuadradas unidades cuadradas y
puede ser cualquier unidad cuadrada
aunque hay estas unidades pueden ser
centímetros y este rectángulo tiene un
área de 268 centímetros cuadrados o
puede ser que estés viendo este
rectángulo desde el cielo muy lejos y en
realidad son 268 kilómetros cuadrados o
millas cuadradas aunque pero como no
queremos determinar cuáles son las
unidades
vamos a dejarlo así unidades cuadradas
ok ahora digamos que además conocemos
alguna de estas dos dimensiones
por ejemplo digamos que sabemos cuánto
mide este lado y además digamos que mide
dos unidades
una vez y bueno si este lado mide dos
unidades este rectángulo no está
dibujado precisamente en proporción
porque en realidad para medir dos
unidades tendría que tener una altura
más o menos de este tamaño pero entonces
no se vería mucho como un rectángulo
aunque entonces vamos a dejarlo así son
dos unidades de alto y sabemos que el
área total son 268 unidades cuadradas
entonces como conocemos el área y
conocemos uno de los lados tiene todo el
sentido preguntarnos por cuánto mide el
otro lado aunque el otro lado de este
rectángulo
ahora nosotros sabemos que si
multiplicamos la longitud de este lado
por la longitud de este otro lado lo que
obtenemos es el área total del
rectángulo entonces para encontrar esta
longitud podemos empezar tomando el área
total del rectángulo osea 268 y
dividirla entre la longitud del otro
lado aunque ello sea entre 2 y esto lo
que nos va a dar es la longitud de este
lado
268 entre 2 es la longitud de este lado
y ya hemos visto varias formas de sacar
esta división pero la razón por la que
estamos viendo este rectángulo o esta
vista desde lejos de este terreno
rectangular es para tener una forma
visual de representar a la división pero
bueno una forma de hacer esta división
es separar
de todo el rectángulo en áreas que son
más fáciles de imaginar dividiendo entre
dos aquí tengo exactamente el mismo
terreno pero los separé en tres áreas
distintas que vas a ver que son más
fáciles de dividir entre dos aunque hoy
por aquí este lado sigue midiendo dos
unidades unidades pero separe el área
del rectángulo en tres pedazos gate este
pedazo azul tiene un área de 200
unidades cuadradas el pedazo amarillo
tiene un área de 60 unidades cuadradas y
finalmente este pedazo rosa tiene un
área de ocho unidades cuadradas ahora
porque es útil hacer esto
bueno pues porque cada una de estas
áreas es más fácil de dividir entre dos
y aquí tal cual esta área de 268
unidades cuadradas las separamos en tres
área
distintas 1 que mide 200 unidades
cuadradas otra que mide 60 unidades
cuadradas 60 y una última que mide ocho
unidades cuadradas y ahora sí ya que
separamos a toda esta área en tres
pedazos que son muy fáciles de dividir
entre dos lo que queremos es dividirlo
entre dos y podemos hacer eso dividiendo
cada uno de estos pedazos entre dos y
eso es justo lo que vamos a hacer
ahorita aunque ahora lo que queremos
saber es cuál es esta dimensión de aquí
y cuánto vale esta longitud de aquí y
cuánto vale esta longitud de aquí pues
bueno lo que sabemos es que dos por esta
longitud de aquí es igual a 200 entonces
esto tiene que medir
y como sabemos que tiene que ser 100
pues porque 200 200 entre 2 entre 2 es
igual a 100 y ahora vamos por acá aunque
hay cuánto es 60 entre 2 o sea cuánto
vale este lado pues 60 entre 2 es 30 así
es que esta área de aquí esta área de 60
unidades cuadradas es el área de esta
parte del rectángulo que tiene dos
unidades de altura y 30 unidades de
largo y finalmente cuánto mide este
pedazo de longitud pues mide 8 entre 2 y
cuánto es 8 entre 24 y observa 2% es 202
por 30 de 62 por 4 es 8 y la longitud
total cuánto mide
este lado del rectángulo es 100 más 30
más 4
o sea 134 134 y ya hemos visto otras
formas de hacer esta división por
ejemplo podemos tomar lo que hay aquí
tenemos dos centenas las dividimos entre
dos y entonces tenemos una sola centena
tenemos seis decenas dividimos entre dos
y nos quedan tres decenas y ocho
unidades divididas entre dos son cuatro
unidades pero hacer eso es exactamente
lo que acabamos de hacer aquí ok porque
lo que hicimos fue tomar este número y
si lo estamos visualizando aquí con un
rectángulo o con un terreno visto desde
lejos que es una buena forma de
visualizar números y como los dividimos
entre dos pero tomamos ese terreno y lo
separamos en tres pedazos uno que es el
pedazo de terreno que representa
centenas o sea a 200 otro pedazo de
terreno que representa 6 decenas o sea
60 y un último pedazo de terreno que
representa 8 unidades y luego para cada
uno de estos terrenos separados
encontramos esta longitud de aquí y para
obtener la longitud total lo único que
tenemos que hacer es sumar estos pedazos
de longitud y listo
ok ahora ésta es sólo una forma de
hacerlo en la que partimos al número en
todos sus valores posicionales sea
centenas decenas y unidades pero no
siempre tenemos que partir tanto a un
número que hay veces en que es más fácil
si lo partimos un poquito menos por
ejemplo digamos que este rectángulo 1856
ciudades
cuadradas
y digamos que esta longitud de aquí esta
longitud de aquí es de 8 unidades
como vamos a partir a este rectángulo de
tal forma que sea súper fácil encontrar
cuál es la otra longitud que da y cuál
es esta longitud y esta longitud otra
vez va a ser 856 entre 8 mil 856 entre 8
esto es cuánto mide esta longitud de
aquí y para partir 856 pues si podríamos
partirlo en 8 centenas 5 decenas y 6
unidades pero eso tal vez no sería lo
más fácil porque cinco decenas no es tan
fácil de dividir entre ocho si se puede
hacer pero no es tan fácil sin embargo
si juntamos las decenas con las unidades
si tenemos 56 eso sí es mucho más fácil
de dividir
8 porque 8 por 7 56 entonces podemos
partir a todo el rectángulo en dos
pedazos uno que mida 800 unidades
cuadradas y otro que mida 56 unidades
cuadradas así es que lo acabamos de
partir en 8 centenes aquí están las 8
centenas 800 y 56 unidades aquí están
las 56 unidades cuadradas ok tienen
exactamente la misma área pero la
separamos en dos pedazos muy
convenientes y bueno sabemos que este
lado mide ocho unidades así es que si
queremos saber cuánto mide este otro
lado de aquí
pues tenemos este pedazo de rectángulo
que tiene un área de 800 unidades
cuadradas y uno de sus lados mide ocho
unidades entonces este lado tiene que
medir 800 entre 8 y 800 entre 8 y 100
así es que este lado mide 100 como
obtuve este 100 dividiendo 800 entre 8
gray entre 8 y ahora vamos con el último
pedacito de esta longitud queremos saber
cuánto vale este pedazo de longitud y
para obtenerlo lo que tenemos que hacer
es dividir 56 entre 8 56 entre 8 y 56
entre 8 y 7 porque 7 por 8 el 56
entonces cuánto mide todo este al lado
del rectángulo cuanto vale esta longitud
pues mide 100 más
7 o sea 107 y otra vez pudiste haber
simplemente tomado 856 y haber dicho
mirar 8 caben 800 100 veces y luego 8
caben 56 7 veces y listo entonces porque
dibujos al todos estos rectángulos se
hizo todo este relajo y la razón es que
a veces es muy útil visualizar las cosas
ok y las divisiones como podemos ver
aquí son un problema de área si tenemos
un número y decimos que ese es el área y
estamos dividiendo entre otro número que
decimos que es uno de los lados entonces
la división va a ser la longitud del
otro lado y cuando estés haciendo la
división y lo par estás en valores
posicionales como generalmente se hacen
las divisiones o cuando los partes en
pedazos que sean todavía más fáciles de
resolver
puedes visualizarlo como que está
separada
el área en distintos pedazos ok
aquí está 100 y aquí está 7
en fin espero que haya mejorado tu
habilidad para visualizar divisiones
especialmente las divisiones muy largas